[Music]
bachelor nation couple Amanda Stanton
and Josh Murray are over I'm in love
with Josh yeah I feel like it was kind
of like an instant thing for me the pair
got together on bachelor in paradise in
the spring even getting engaged at the
end of the season but a source tells et
Amanda called it off a couple weeks ago
what their relationship had been on the
rocks for a while people were surprised
they were together for as long as they
were we love each other
we're having a blast he was just with
the couple at Jingle Ball in LA on
December 4th give me a relationship
update what's going on we're having a
lot of fun
I mean we live out here in Irvine so
only a couple hours away from here we're
enjoying life enjoying the kids and have
a good time are you guys making it work
like how hard is that transition from
island life to real life I mean it's
different and you know when here we were
dating on the show it was like we didn't
have any distractions we were away from
work we didn't have her cell phones I
was away from my kids just like
everything so it's like then we got back
to real life and he moved across the
country to live with us and we move yeah
it's been different but it's been good
we like it
you